un homme scruté pour une opération de
communication
joe biden soixante dix huit ans
s'apprête à se faire vacciner avec le
soutien sans faille de son épouse je
fais ça pour montrer que les gens
doivent être prêts à se faire vacciner
lorsque ce sera possible de le faire il
n'y a pas de quoi s'inquiéter
j'attends avec impatience la deuxième
injection tout comme gilles elle s'est
fait vacciner plus tôt dans la journée
elle a dans les piqûres
je sais le président élu des etats unis
décontracté après une première injection
du vaccin provenant du laboratoire
américain pfizer le premier des deux
vaccins être autorisées sur le
territoire de doses sont nécessaires
pour être immunisé contre le coc vie 19
nous devons beaucoup à ces gens les
scientifiques et les personnes qui ont
mis cela en place les travailleurs de
première ligne
les personnes qui ont fait le travail
clinique c'est tout simplement
incroyable
vous savez ce n'est que le début c'est
une chose de faire sortir le vaccin est
maintenant moderna va être sur la route
aussi
mais cela va prendre du temps cela va
prendre du temps joe biden a appelé les
américains à pratiquer la distanciation
sociale en ces fêtes de fin d'année avec
un port du masque est essentielle si
vous n'avez pas un voyage et ne voyagez
pas at il martelé
joe biden érigé en exemple tout comme
cette infirmière de l'état du
connecticut première patiente à recevoir
une dose de notre vaccin américain celui
de modern à ce dernier
homologué par l'agencé américaine du
médicament vendredi dernier à la
différence du vaccin des laboratoires
pfizer et bio n tech qui nécessitent des
contenaires spécifique de livraison le
lac sans moderna peut être conservé à
moins 20 degrés et non mans 70 degrés ce
vaccin est un espoir un espoir de
stopper cette pandémie de vivre une
meilleure vie nous ne devons pas avoir
peur de nous faire vacciner
ça me donne la tranquillité d'esprit de
me faire vacciner est de savoir que je
ne serai pas un vecteur qui affectera
mes patients ou qui ramènera le virus
dans ma famille et ma communauté pour le
vaccin moderna parce qu'il est un peu
plus facile à stocker nous allons nous
concentrer sur ce vaccin exclusivement
en dehors des hôpitaux dans notre groupe
médical et dans tous les hôpitaux de
campagne que nous établissons pour la
vaccination personnel médical et
résidents des maisons de retraite en
première ligne pompiers enseignants
employés de petites et grandes surfaces
seront les prochains à se faire vacciner
en priorité selon les derniers chiffres
des autorités
7,9 millions de vaccins seront
distribués cette semaine dans le pays